[Musique]
un bijou patrimonial de style beaux-arts
des escaliers finement sculptées des
fresques par de grands maîtres
le château dufresne a été construit en
pleine première guerre mondiale
les frères dufresne des bourgeois
canadiens français établis dans l'actuel
quartier hochelaga maisonneuve
ce sont des gens qui ont voulu implanter
une bourgeoisie francophone dans l'est
de montréal alors que le secteur ici
était quasi rural et en s'inspirant des
grands coureurs balistique
ils ont voulu implanter le une ville
modèle une ville où il fait bon vivre le
château dufresne est l'un des quatorze
musique qui participe cette semaine au
premier festival d'histoire de montréal
le château ramezay figure aussi un autre
lieu exceptionnel chargé d'histoire
cette année on célèbre le 125e
anniversaire de l'existence du musée
mais si on en effet amusé c'est parce
qu'il avait ni un riche passé
c'est comme on dit souvent un témoin de
bien des moments de notre histoire de
claude de ramezay gouverneur de montréal
à 10 705 en passant par la présence
américaine en 1775 la compagnie des ânes
lord elgin et bien d'autres ici on
proposera des activités spéciales toute
la fin de semaine
toute la programmation est élaborée
sur une grille d'expérience de
l'histoire goûter l'histoire jouer rires
l'histoire témoigne et d'histoire
l'histoire n'est pas quelque chose de
figé
elle est en mouvement l'afro musée qui
ouvrira officiellement ses portes dans
quelques semaines se jouait aussi au
festival et demande aux internautes de
participer à une carte interactive
on est dit qu'en dix lieux importants de
l'histoire des communautés afro
montréalaise
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
ouvert c'est-à-dire il ya c'est de
donner la parole aux africains aux afro
descendants mais aussi à leurs alliés ou
les personnes qui s'intéressent à sa
ayant beaucoup que ce soit pour
découvrir l'histoire des soeurs
hospitalières
nous comprendre l'évolution de la rue
amherst devenu had a gun le festival
d'histoire de montréal
c'est plus de 30 activités en personne
et en ligne pour célébrer la richesse de
notre histoire ici n'est bien alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal
[Musique]